nadie lo era decidió hacer pública su
acusación de violencia familiar al ver
que su expareja buscaba ser candidato al
gobierno de ahome sinaloa su antes no
había mencionado es nada era mi vida
privada y me está defendiendo en los
tribunales sí y de los tribunales pero
cuando él se lance dice yo quiero hacer
le baje la mano tú no puedes ser tú eres
un agresor
en una suerte de mitú político en un
continente donde el machismo es poco
mediatizado la determinación de nadie
quiso que su ex esposo quedara fuera de
la competencia es una violencia en su
vertiente psicológica económica
patrimonial y abandona la familia
entonces estas violencias son
silenciosas pero lacerantes como la que
más no ser acosador para apoyar a esas
mujeres que denuncian agresores
yndira sandoval y su colectiva
impulsaron la regla tres de tres sobre
uno no ser deudor de pensión alimenticia
2 no ser agresor sexual incluyendo el
acoso y el hostigamiento y 3 no ser
agresor en el ámbito público ni privado
contra las mujeres y para aquellos
agresores que a pesar de todo alcanzaron
una candidatura diseñaron un método de
exposición pública en las redes sociales
las anti boletas muestran el cargo al
que están siendo postulados el partido
que los postulan el municipio distrito
estado con el que están participando y
el delito por el que están siendo
acusados estas elecciones son de las más
violentas en méxico un país con mucha
violencia de género también por lo que
la valentía de las mujeres que resisten
es aún más valiosa